[Music]  I truly just do the best I can do for my  body because I know that I'm not going  to ever have those curves and that ass  and that waistline that's just not my  body and I'm fine with that Chrissy  Teigen is confident in her own skin and  she's not afraid to show off her  flawless figure her curves or edges are  perfect imperfections John Legend's wife  made time for some TLC posting a pic on  snapchat going makeup free and stripping  down to nothing captioned finally a  spray tan Thank You Fiona  I think it's really important the model  has never shied away from sharing her  beauty secrets on social media or  documenting the ups and downs of  motherhood like when her pregnancy glow  faded away leaving a red blemish  no  [Music]